after a nearly four-month delay it is
finally time to play ball the major
league baseball season is set to begin
tonight after the pandemic
shut things down for some time the first
game is scheduled for the nation's
capital
the world champion washington nationals
will take on the new york yankees and ed
o'keefe is outside
nationals park ed good morning i'm
guessing no baby shark in the fans
tonight
well no because that guy got traded but
that's a long story look not only will
teams look different this season
because several high-profile players
opted not to play this abbreviated
season amid the pandemic
but the way the game is played will
actually be different due to league
restrictions on who can be in the
stadium
and how exactly the teams play ball
after last baseball season ended like
this the washington nationals are world
champions
fans might be shocked to see the 2020
season begin
like this stadium seats will be empty
replaced in some cities by cardboard
cutouts celebrations will be distanced
coaches will be masked and fan noise
will be piped in
over stadium speakers similar
precautions were taken in korea and
japan
when those countries brought back
baseball earlier this year
although you may not see many dancing
robots
other u.s leagues have been exploring
different structures
major league soccer has been holding a
world cup style tournament this month in
florida
and the nba is coming back next week
with no fans in attendance
after a nearly five-month hiatus and
delays caused by coronavirus outbreaks
at team facilities i'm an avid
washington national fan dr
anthony fauci showed support for his
favorite team at a congressional hearing
last month
and tonight he's throwing out the first
pitch as a different kind of season
gets underway there's not going to be
people in the stands
it's just going to be televised so i
think that in and of itself
tells you something about the stark
difference between what we're doing
right now
and what we were able to do last year at
this time i used to play baseball
as a young boy as a kid in school and
i hope i don't bounce it too much
and on this opening day the toronto blue
jays are still looking for
a new nest so to speak that's because
canada rejected their request to play
games at home
because they don't want american players
crossing the border and potentially
infecting canadians
plans to move to pnc park in pittsburgh
were nixed
by pennsylvania state health officials
because of a surge there
so we'll see exactly where the blue jays
land anthony you know every once in a
while they have a bobble head night
at ball parks across the country they
won't be selling this one
but i'm rooting for anthony fauci
tonight
as a fellow little league dropout that
whole concern about
letting it bounce before hitting home
plate yeah that's real i have complete
faith with him
whatever he does will be fine i'm just
glad to have baseball and it was the
highlight of my morning anticipating
an ed o'keefe piece on opening day
thanks dad